math really oily oh my god no Chow my
name is Ludovico would you also know
Valentino I'm the video hey how's it
going I'm Massimiliano and to their
words for an Italian food from Trader
Joe's oh my God look good ways it's kind
of offensive it's okay I can try this
look overcooked already
yeah they look very overcooked I mean
this is like you know bad memories from
childhood when you went to like this
cool and they did like overcooked no I
can't but I mean the sauce is nice right
pesto has some flavored flowerpower
Drago they didn't get anything right
with this dish missing salt the way was
cooked is overcooked not enough sauce
stick in the mouth amen that's horrible
no I'm not gonna eat that again I
wouldn't eat this again
I'm sorry I would rather make it myself
or have my mom made it to be honest my
grandmother will scream at this a PITA
from Trader Joe's I can sell oh my god
pizza oh can I try kind of go up five
oh I can sell so that this is like a
frozen type that you have to understand
yeah put it yeah I can tell cause it
looks kind of plasticky and I'm hungry
any breakfast would be what sticking on
the plate that's not good oh I think
it's wrong
yeah would you like to take the few ice
if you pass out I know Monty
well it's missing a little bit of salt
and the crust is no crust the eyes it's
very soft
mmm but I would eat this okay it's not
that bad
it leaves a little more oregano and yell
the consistency of the the crafted the
dough is not that bad like you can tell
it was frozen before but it's actually
pretty good from from one to ten the
mozzarella taste good the tomato sauce
is good it wouldn't eat meat a little
bit more salt a little bit more like
crunchiness but overall it's a path so
obviously this is not comparable to
these pizza that we're used to in Italy
but you know if you're watching game
games of thrones or your you know
Netflix and chill and you need the
little bite and you wanna think you're
eating Italian that's a good number like
we thought snack a good snack Italians
don't need frozen pizza neither fresh
from scratch and me that's the answer
good job case closed
whip it back oh my god
no it's Debbie's I think it reminds me
of a sausage so that's definitely not
the kind of meat you put in the meatball
man it's really oily juicy as we say in
the south we used to maple pitted the
smaller because they have to fit with
the resume they have to fit with the
tomato sauce so this is already a little
this is like a lady in the [ __ ]
meatballs that's why it's math like
Burger King mint
it smells like cardboard and I never
even ate cardboard it's a little spice
and they're not spicy but it has I think
pepper in it it's not bad I think it
lacks of cheese because when you make
meatballs you put cheese now that the
flavor is more in my house they taste
more like cardboard no plastic it tastes
it is like plastic it tastes very holy
and it doesn't even taste like a go
durian tastes like like frypan yeah but
like you hold the fry pan oil yeah
doesn't taste like meat no mm-hmm I
would not eat it again I'm still trying
to figure out what I'm eating cuz it's
like yeah
I cannot even figure out the taste this
is probably for an American stand
standard but from any time point of view
I wouldn't eat them again it's like a
quick fast meal fasting that you just
pop in the microwave if you're hungry
and it's 12 a.m. but it's not a true
Italian meatball put beta so Trader
Joe's good try
I'm sorry but next time did I really say
that it tasted like cardboard yes you
did I was expecting bad and that's what
I got I don't like this restaurant but
the pizza was good so one point two
threads oh sure and that's it because
only pizza was good what I was expecting
you know knowing Trader Joe's
was a surprise a little more surprise
from them so apart from pizza which was
you know good the rest was a little
disappointing
the rest was look man they the beats if
that were bad but they weren't that bad
the board bit they were surprisingly
horrible for me they were horrible yeah
seems like corny pasta was divorce I
would say let's stick to like vegetables
and chips and Trader Joe's and like the
Italian maybe let's let's get it
somewhere else I wouldn't go for Trader
Joe's for this I would go for treasure
just don't hang any other things fruit
vegetable water Fiji water olive oil
there because that's it's in a modified
yeah they do is another filter filter
olive oil it's very dark color and you
really taste the audience
absolutely no like my grandma for sure
but still good
the wine is good you're 21 and over
we're open-minded Trader Joe's we love
you you can sponsor me
[Music]
you